So an important consideration
in what we're doing here
is that our state is a single number.
It's an integer.
That way we can address
it in our cue table.
It is certainly the case that some
reinforcement learning methods
are able to treat the state
as a continuous value.
But just to get started here,
let's use state as an integer so
we can work more easily with the data.
Now we have to do a little bit of work
to get our state to an integer and
here is the general way to do it.
Our first step is to
discretize each factor.
It's a weird word,
I'll explain it in a moment.
But it essentially means convert
that real number into an integer.
Next is combine all of those integers
together into a single number.
We're assuming that we're using
a discrete state space and
that means more or less that our overall
state is going to be this one integer
that represents at once
all of our factors.
So consider that we have four factors
and each one is a real number.
Now we have separately beforehand
figured out how to discretize
each one of these factors.
So we run each of these factors through
their individual discretizers and
we get an integer.
Now I've happened to select
integers between 0 and 9 but
you can have larger ranges, for
instance 0 to 20 or 0 to 100 even.
It's easy if we just go from 0
to 9 because then we can stack
them together into a number.
But it's not too hard to think of
algorithms will enable you to combine
larger ranges of integers together.
In this case we're just able to
stack them one after the other
into our overall discretized state.